[Music]
what is grief
if not love
persevering
part of the madness of the multiverse is
we get to see different realities and we
see different versions primarily of dr
strange but we do see other versions of
wanda maximo
i think wandavision was this journey of
her for the first time taking her own
life into her own hands and it was fun
transitioning from her experience to
this movie you could use an avenger
there are other avengers i'll get you
back in the lunchbox
what do you know about the multiverse
we wanted to satisfy the one division
fans and take them to the next level
with a character they loved
it was fun just looking at it from a
different perspective
the multiverse
this had his theories
he believed it was dangerous
we need your help
it's magical she owns that character so
well it's a very powerful performance
with a very powerful character
in the multiverse there are alternate
versions of everyone it gives the
characters unique opportunity to meet
themselves
to recognize qualities that they may
have been blind you
the fate of the multiverse depends on us
[Music]